welcome to this video yeah offbeat week
and I'm trying to be offbeat on move to
after good out of moves to try maybe
this one that is I think sufficiently
off bead i recently tried that in one of
the live streams and i won a game
actually with it so it turned out to be
quite ok yep and i'm getting i don't
know ok he's tried to open up there
let's go away for quickly and see 94 now
he has got Bishop f6 at the end she
probably just left to take yeah that
looks quite solid solid for like maybe
deform yeah yeah let's go default don't
want to try too much after Bishop f6 oh
that's boring boring chromis boring ok
it's probably not a bad move can I not
trade 33 maybe can go to e3 ok
I might get a temple on the queen is
probably not a bad move at actually
Queen you three I will get some kind of
tempo Bishop c4 that Bishop d3 d4 or
something like that and then e five
under control that's not such a bad
position already looks quite okay I'm
pretty amazed that I have a distance
courses up with those of bid openings I
expected to have more problems I mean
maybe we would why did some there
there's a little bit more that you can
allow it or that you allow that you can
afford let's say the wrong wrong word
alone let's see an item before is of
course quite annoying um no I cannot go
if I but it's closed it's closed yep
that makes lots of sense but that also I
think so should be fine so I'm going to
check here and I've got a very nice
development
Wow okay yeah okay it hangs it does hang
too so going 45 or something I don't
know don't know maybe so let's go ahead
for him see that v5 is not so easily
possible that's an unprotected piece
there but maybe I have no way to exploit
it maybe Bishop c6f5 forever that looks
quite dangerous so I cannot play Bishop
c6 as usually every time but I say how I
cannot play that he will play that
opponent will do that invariably I this
is really can I was bad on it yeah I
thought that night e 7 and the pressure
on f7 really would be far too much to
stand but maybe I'm wrong okay so let's
see that's very dangerous this night
though is annoying some look lift would
be great but hard to get in
I don't know if that is a good move here
but okay I have to have to play not
spending more time and the stages media
is looming really is that sacrifice on
h7 where you can check on the edge file
set set set possible somehow where is he
actually going with that Queen to e4
maybe no not going to them to that not
going there so I'm going for here I
really I really want to get that made
and it's very very one-sided way to play
but still okay he's out for he's really
out for Queen here I get that that funky
made and somehow thanks i really really
want to get that in
nikon d4s really bad Billy annoying that
one
hmm can take you to
I don't see how to get that in I would
love to sit in a way playing for tricks
but I really like that mate it's one of
the one of the one of the cute cute the
mates each floor will probably not help
with it it's okay
time morning in that move okay that
that'sthat's lots of pieces on the king
it's going to check on h1 check so we
threatening here now unfortunately
rocked it to again it's not really great
here I've given up all the pawns I'm
just going all of them really
for look H form
it's not so easy for him 20 seconds I
have
it's really just playing for it is a
dangerous attack whatever you why don't
really know how he should try to defend
now got everything on this King all
pieces
I asked to give the Queen now I think
covering the night that's important ouch
is 60 threaten now okay come out that
one night has no squares let's keep that
Luke f6 was an idea yeah give 64 age six
black for fits on time Wow yeah I don't
know hey I mean I have every piece on
his skin but probably what I was just
fishing a little bit here and trying
form c3 is strong yeah I only briefly
thought about the idea just his free and
kick the night back yeah I was too
fascinated by it but trying to get this
this checkmate going there with the
white is actually winning him now the
tech is too strong it's very difficult
to analyze this kind of thing now with
limited time but campuzano plus five it
doesn't see any defense here yeah and
just to show the medicine because well
like here this is chess Anastasia's
magnate that was water what I was
angling for all of the time for the
night only seven there were some other
nice mates at the end here when here
here went age 6 unfortunately he went
age 6 if he plays any move like here
yeah I plane I'd g6 io again I can play
an asterias made I saw i saw that made
check it's not not necessary but it's
nate quite cute but ok it's not
necessary dumb
I originally thought this would would
also win by mate but it's no made it
wins yeah i mean i can check check with
all kinds of material but yeah okay
white white is essentially a queen up no
need to analyze this here yeah the b3
line is not term not exactly mainstream
so i think it counts as offbeat and that
was actually I think white okay white
white should be okay in this position
Queen d5 yeah I wanted to keep the
greens on and it seems justified so
something else here no thanks to yeah I
really what I really think that that
justice looked very risky I mean just
allowing f5 I don't know I don't know it
he has something completely different
rookie aid or something I look d8 for
example but just allow the night here on
f5 look super dangerous yeah from here I
was only playing for one idea okay well
thanks for watching